I think news is amazing I think he's a
modern-day hero I think everything that
he's done is just so inspirational I
think the long swim has really brought
to everyone's attention how important
our seas are and how important it all it
is for all of us do a bit to protect
them to restore them to health and to
make sure that this amazing
environmental resources there for future
generations and Lewis's courage his grit
his amazing dedication I think is an
example to us all so what is your
message to environment secretaries like
Michael Gove here in the UK and
elsewhere you're heading off to New York
obviously what do you want to say well
it's an opportunity now for Britain
really to lead at the moment in terms of
global leadership there's a vacuum in
terms of protecting our oceans I think
this is a natural place for Britain to
be in terms of protecting our oceans not
only here around the UK but also our
overseas territories I'd like Michael to
be going to the g7 summit and showing
the other g7 nations and also in to the
United Nations that we talked the talk
that we when it comes to ocean
protection we do the job it's very very
difficult for us to be encouraging other
nations to to do the same thing if we
and Britain are not leading right we've
already taken some steps to protect the
waters around around this country but
there is more that we need to do and
there's more that we also need to do in
order to to galvanize a global coalition
in order to make sure that our oceans
are purged of plastic but more broadly
that we also have more protected areas
in which we we stop the exploitation of
our seas and allow nature to recover but
we only have three fully non exploitable
parts of the UK water don't we bloody
Island Aran a small part of Yorkshire
only three it's not really doing
anything is it more needs to be done
you're right that more needs to be done
we've already said that there will be
more marine protected areas and more
marine conservation zones around the
really genuinely do it you convinced
that's actually the point cuz sometimes
you're detecting one species from one
specific activity in a small area you
need to protect the whole ecosystem and
the whole habitat I think there's always
got to be a balance which is struck in
order to make sure that coastal
communities can continue to fish but in
a sustainable way and one of the lessons
of Lewis's
swim is that we will only ensure that we
have fishing industry in the future if
we make sure that we have sustainable
resources now and it's striking that
balance which it's important we all do
and we have to do globally we have to
recognize that there are some parts of
our seas and oceans which need to be
completely protected which should be no
take zones there are other areas where
the right sort of fishing can carry on
provided it's sustainable and
environmentally sensible we've seen
scalloped walls what you've been in the
water
they've been battles off the coast of
Normandy fighting over the scraps of
what's left of the scallop industry
there and these are fishermen being
attacked British fishermen being
attacked see it's exactly what you're
talking about it's a very very
interesting thing you know Desmond Tutu
always says when we damage the
environment we create conditions ripe
for conflict and so so many of the
conflicts which are taking place around
the world today by taking place as a
result of of of a conflict over limited
resources and he also says that when we
protect the environments we foster peace
so when I see images of British
fishermen and French fishermen fighting
I think to myself we really have to do
absolutely everything now to protect the
environment to avoid this type of
conflict with our neighbours here in
France it's a real concern for the
government to see stuff like that as
well isn't it it's deeply concerning my
heart goes out to all the fishermen
who've been caught up in this as you
know and I'm from a fishing background
myself and I do have enormous sympathy
and I think it's important that we as we
are doing talk to the French government
make sure that those fishermen who are
fishing legally are protected as they go
about their work and we also need to
make sure that in the future we've got
the right regime in order to ensure
exactly as Lewis says that we have
healthy and sustainable resources for
for the future we're talking about the
politics of scallop fishing and here you
are not even feeling the cold that you
need to go and get what's your favorite
food well it's range so I started on
chocolate and then then it was potatoes
and for the last I don't know four weeks
it's been hot cross buns hot cross buns
and it's not even Easter I think we need
to get you a hot cross bun Lewis Pugh
it's amazing too to see what you've done
I have to say you'd have lost me on
jumping in I think we can all probably
say that none of us would really like to
do that but
how do you feel about having finally
completed what has been a long-held goal
of yours to swim the English Channel and
become a record breaker it's an absolute
relief but just remembering this wasn't
about breaking records this was this was
not about swimming this was about trying
to convey a message to people here
around the UK that we have a very very
precious resource and that we must
protect it for not only our generation
but most importantly for future
generation and also for the animal
kingdom how did he do everyone what do
you think
[Applause]